we're following breaking news this
morning one person dead after a
suspected road rage shooting in the
south valley roads on i-15 are 215
rather closed the suspect on the loose
hector mahia live near 2 15 in warm
springs with new details from metro
hector hernandez hour police need the
public's help tracking down that gunman
someone shot into the victim's car
killing the male driver and critically
wounding his female passenger the
suspected road rage shooting happened
along the eastbound lanes of the 215.
right now the highway shut down between
las vegas boulevard and warm springs
police say they have a vague vehicle
description for the shooter possibly a
four-door gray colored sedan victims
believed to be in their mid-20s and
right now police are wrapping up their
investigation right behind us but they
hope to reopen within the hour let's
send it over to nate tannenbaum who's
standing by with a detour good morning
nate good morning hector this has been a
really crazy commute for you because so
the freeways are super crowded here
there's a crash on the south 95 at
flamingo but the big story is that
deadly roads road rage shooting shutting
down the 215 basically from decatur all
the way to warm springs they continue
their investigation so far it is still
closed
and we're going to keep an eye on it for
the west